now clearly Law and Order is something
that Americans value and for good reason
because without safety life becomes very
difficult when you have woke DA's
refusing to prosecute even violent
criminals and recommending leaning
sentences in the name of quote social
justice they are hurting their own
community so what can be done well out
in Missouri the Attorney General is now
working to fire a St Louis circuit
attorney named kin Kim Gardner now keep
in mind St Louis is one of the most
dangerous cities on Earth and in return
Gardner is now playing the race card
take a look at this
while it is true my office could have
done more
to say we did nothing is only
disingenuous but it's willfully ignorant
of the reality of our court system
we're going to fight very hard for
justice in spite of the vitriol the hate
the racist attacks the known
manipulation of the court procedures to
make sure our office fails
all right joining us Now to respond
Missouri attorney general Andrew Paley
is with us sir welcome to the program
um
let's start with what it is that this
attorney is doing what Kim Gardner is
doing and why it is she should not be
holding this position because what we
have is a phenomenon we have the funding
of very weak on Law and Order uh
candidates being funded being elected to
office only because of the money spent
and they don't they don't enforce the
laws of the land they don't prosecute
criminals and Americans now are at risk
as a result your thoughts
yeah look this is about the rule of law
and justice for victims I come from a
prosecutor's office I've used
prosecutorial discretion to determine
whether or not I have sufficient
evidence to pursue cases and that's what
prosecutorial discretion is about it is
not and after the fact veto to nullify
laws you don't like so if you don't want
to enforce laws don't take a job as a
prosecutor but what we have in the city
of St Louis is a circuit attorney who is
illegally unlawfully willfully neglected
her duties and she's done that in three
ways she's failed to prosecute pending
cases that then languish on the dockets
and are eventually dismissed she's
failed to inform and confer with victims
which is her constitutional and
statutory not to mention her moral
obligation and she's also failed to file
new charges referred to her by law
enforcement officers so we're going to
stand up and fight for the rule of law
and for justice for these victims let's
talk about her failure to notify or
confer with victims let's talk about the
Daniel Riley case a teenage athlete walk
back to a hotel in downtown St Louis in
February
Miss Edmondson and her family walk down
the sidewalk a speeding car Daniel Riley
crashing into another car striking Miss
Edmondson uh severing one of her legs
maiming another what happened in that
case
well look defendant Riley should have
been locked up in jail awaiting trial he
was arrested for a violent offense and
should not have been out on bond but
after he was out on bond he committed
numerous Bond violations and the circuit
attorney never moved to revoke his bond
now she will tell you that she made oral
motion in court and that it's the
Court's fault his bond wasn't revoked
but she has a responsibility here and
here's the thing that she's got a
problem with everything that happens in
court is transcribed there are court
records in the form of electronic docket
entries and there are memos that become
part of the court record and what she's
saying happen is directly refuted by the
evidence in this case she says that on
August 10th she fought against bond for
Mr Riley and yet the the transcript from
that hearing shows she consented to the
bond so her her statements don't add up
and luckily we have evidence to disprove
them but this isn't about just one case
this is a continuous pattern of behavior
that constitutes an illegal willful
neglect in office all right so do you
believe if you have the capacity to
finally remove her
that is exactly what we're doing we
filed a writ of quo warrento it's a
legal mechanism provided in statute by
The People's elected representatives
that empowers me to take this action
it's a check and balance at the state
level against this kind of behavior and
it's time for the circuit attorney to go
and the rule of law and Justice to
Prevail all right attorney general Billy
we appreciate your time thank you sir
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else